an experimental coronavirus vaccine
moves into human testing today it's part
of the push by scientists to find
treatments and preventive vaccines our
dr. David agus joins us from Los Angeles
David good morning I know a vaccine is
is at least a year away at this point so
I want to get to the sort of more
immediate concern which is has been the
lack of tests is the testing situation
improving at all from what you've seen
you know the good is there are more
tests across the country the tough part
is there's not an infrastructure to run
those tests and some of the reagents are
in short supply so the real answer is
we're still testing a fraction of the
people that need to be tested and the
tests many times can take three four or
five days until the results come back
so David does that limit our
understanding of what we're dealing with
at this point you know with knowledge is
power and right now we don't have that
knowledge so it's very hard to do
effective data-driven quarantined
without the data of who's infected if I
told you you're positive you're gonna
stay home yeah but now it's
indeterminate we don't know what to do
so what are the numbers and other
countries tell us about what we could
face here does does that give us any
clue yeah no question about it is that
we're scared I mean we're scared that
the numbers are going to skyrocket that
we're gonna have to put in stricter
measures I'm proud of what America is
doing we are stepping up every single
you know city is stepping up here we may
have to step up more but it's certainly
an amazing week and look at what we've
done as a country the doctor at the
beginning of this month we are at fewer
than a hundred cases now we're at 3,700
and when you look at our trajectory next
to Italy and Iran it seems frightening
ly similar are we on of the path of say
Italy you know it's really hard to know
is that certainly we have much better
medical infrastructure than Italy does
the drugs that are going to be able to
treat this disease are in development
and look very very encouraging so the
hope is there's some really positive
news there in the next week or two
together with us expanding our medical
infrastructure we will not have what
happened what happen in Italy
I think our leadership and our
infrastructure is going to do much
better so what do you think we're facing
in in the weeks ahead David what I think
is you know somewhat stricter measures
about trying to slow the progress of the
disease that's the
goal here there's no panic it is slowing
the disease so that we can have our
infrastructure in place we have to
protect our elderly below age 60 the
death rate is almost zero above age 60
it starts to go up by decade and so we
as a country have to protect our elderly
we're all stepping up for people with
medical issues and over the age of 60 to
protect them and if you test positive
David what is the recovery rate do we
know well it depends how old you are so
the entry portal fir that the the virus
goes up by decade so if you test
positive under the age of 60 the
recovery rate is over 99% in countries
like South Korea and it'll be the same
here every decade above 60 that goes up
tell us about you know seven or eight
percent in the 80s and so we have to
protect people over the age of sixty and
that's what we're doing with these
draconian measures that are growing in
across the country doctor doctor there
are some things that you want to spread
at a time like this and that would be
advice for what is effective treatment
when people walk into a doctor's office
I'm curious what what is working what
are folks like yourself talking about
and sharing with one another about how
to get people back on their feet it's a
great question is that right now there
is no national database for what is
working how we all talk to each other in
terms of treating this disease that
being said there are some effective
treatments that we think will work the
clinical trials are ongoing here in the
United States and in China but they
certainly look encouraging and we as
physicians are allowed to use these
drugs what we call off-label so we're
using drugs that block the virus from
replicating we're using drugs that
temper down inflammation which is the
main side effect of the virus to
hopefully make survival significantly
higher than it's been seen before all
right dr. agus thank you very much in
the long term of course we do have hopes
for a vaccine